are you a saleswoman I completely object  to the characterization of being a  salesperson and I but I'm glad you bring  it up because this is you know what I  see so often people say oh you are you  are selling nail i'm not selling Yale  I'm making possible for for an  institution that has a lot to offer in  terms of service to society and to a  person who have the resources to do  something there to get together and do  it in an efficient way that's not  marketing that's not selling that's  that's making a deal no that's enabling  people to treat their dreams and for  institutions like Yale other  universities to really become better and  better and better so so it is there a  way you can capture what you said are  you so you're not a deal maker you're  not a salesperson you are a facilitator  and mediator person who brings people  together very new